the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video
all right my friends in this video i
want to show you something that was said
during a recent interview
i myself thought it was interesting but
dare i say it might even be hopeful for
those of you who are still on the fence
about house of the dragon
the hbo successor show that will be
based on george rr martin's fire and
blood
now as you all know ever since game of
thrones ended millions of fans have said
they are done with not only the main
show
but any other show set in the song of
ice and fire universe that follows after
a lot of them still say now that they
know how game of thrones ends they have
no
interest in watching anything that shows
them how they got there
because at the end of the day it will
all lead to the same thing
while i certainly understand this i do
not agree with it whatsoever
it's no secret there were a lot of
things i did not like about the final
season of game of thrones but i won't
let that affect me when watching house
of the dragon
one of the many good things about this
new series is it already has an ending
the creators of this show already know
what direction it's heading in before
they even make their first episode
this is a luxury the game of thrones
writers dan and dave did not have
they basically had to make things up as
they went along this is a major issue
house of the dragon should be able to
avoid
now another good thing is dan and dave
no longer work for hbo
they're now over at netflix so we don't
have to worry about them dismantling a
good thing
dan and dave also had zero experience in
working for television
i mean hell even hbo didn't have any
experience when it came to creating
these massive fantasy shows but now they
do
even if you hated game of thrones you
cannot deny its success
impact or even influence on other shows
hbo now has a giant notch on their belt
and we can only hope they use all of
this new experience moving forward
i actually think they already have based
on some of the choices they've made
another thing that has me very excited
about house of the dragon is who hbo has
brought back from game of thrones
they have brought back their incredible
composer and best director
so if you're like me and you did love
the way game of thrones looked and
sounded
you will be very happy to know house of
the dragon should have a very similar
sound look and feel to the show it's
almost like hbo got rid of the worst
things about game of thrones like dan
and dave
and kept their best things from game of
thrones like miguel sapochnick
and rameen jawadi i'm assuming most of
you have already seen some of the
costumes as well
hbo has released a handful of official
images that show some of their main
actors and character
now i don't know about you but i think
they look amazing
obviously i'm no costume designer or
fashion expert but i love the way each
of these characters look
i know some of you do have some concerns
about the casting choices they've made
so far
but i have faith in hbo when it comes to
this specifically
at first glance you might think oh this
actor doesn't look right or this
actress's age isn't right for this
character and so on and so forth
however hbo did the same thing with game
of thrones
a lot of the characters from game of
thrones did not look like they would
have in the books
a lot of the actors in game of thrones
were different ages than their
characters from the books
yet hbo still did an amazing job i think
they do an amazing job in all of their
shows like game of thrones the wire
the sopranos deadwood oz the band of
brothers
and so many others who hbo hires as
their actors and actresses is the least
of my concerns because like i said
before
i have faith in them when it comes to
this just wait until you actually see
them during their scenes
now let's think about what we know so
far house of the dragon will be based on
the dance of dragons
this is when house targaryen fought and
killed each other over the iron throne
while on the backs of their dragons so
we already know they are adapting this
show from one of george rr martin's
greatest story set within a song of ice
and fire
there will be more than enough drama for
this show and there will be more than
enough
awesome and interesting characters for
this show as well
that's one thing we do not have to worry
about we also know george rr martin is a
co-creator of the show
so he will be helping them along the way
now how much will he actually help them
i don't know we can only hope he will
guide them when needed
like i said before we also know hbo has
brought back miguel sapochnick the man
responsible for directing some of game
of thrones greatest episodes
as well as rameen jawadi the man
responsible for making some of the
greatest soundtracks in television
history
so we have an amazing story that will
look and sound and feel
very similar to game of thrones which is
what we love
at least when it was good now we just
have to wonder if they will find the
right actors to help bring this amazing
story to life
i think they will based on how well they
have always done on all of their other
shows
including game of thrones now i want to
get to the main reason why i made this
video
there's one other ingredient hbo will
need to ensure house of the dragon
is a success it's arguably the most
important aspect of all
and that is the writing as we have seen
with game of thrones it doesn't matter
how good everything else is if the
writing sucks
game of thrones was always setting a new
example for their acting
their score their costumes their set
design their special effects and so much
more
however when their writing failed so did
the show as a whole
this obviously has a lot of fans worried
about how the writing will be handled
moving forward with their other shows
well like i said before the one good
thing we don't have to worry about
is an ending if you've read the books
you already know the dance of dragons
has an incredible ending
as well as a lot of other amazing major
events that surround it
however there are a lot of big gaps in
the story
unfortunately george has only written
the broad strokes for these events
he hasn't written thousands and
thousands of words of dialogue for all
these characters
so this is something house of the
dragons writers will have to create on
their own
now obviously i won't know how good it
is until the episodes actually release
unless there are leaks but as of right
now that hasn't happened
with that being said there is something
i want to show you that does leave me a
little more optimistic
thanks to a recent interview we have
been given a little more insight into
how good the script is
david peterson who created some of the
different languages on game of thrones
like dothraki and valerian is also
coming back to work on house of the
dragon
well he sat down for an interview and
gave some of his thoughts about the new
show
which i thought were equally exciting
and interesting
what he said about working on house of
the dragon was i can tell you that i'm
very
very excited by it it's a rare thing
that i'm actually super impressed by the
writing in a script
usually it all comes together when you
see it but the writing is really good
so i have sky high hopes for this thing
i really hope it comes off well
and fans like it he also goes on to say
i hope the season 8 naysayers give it a
chance
i totally understand though i totally
get the perspective of somebody who was
like
this show or this movie burned me so i'm
done with the franchise forever
i do actually understand that mentality
in this case i really hope that they
give it a shot
watch the first episode or two with an
open mind that's all i ask
he then notes that a lot of the workers
behind the scenes is coming into this
show after honing their craft on game of
thrones
meaning that everyone is starting at a
very high level basically they're
bringing all of their eight seasons
worth of game of thrones experience to
the very first season of house of the
dragon
what i found most interesting about what
he said was the writing being really
good
now he obviously works on the show so he
doesn't want to trash it before it's
even released
but it does get me even more excited
nonetheless when you take everything
else i said in the video into
consideration as well as what david said
during his interview
i honestly believe house of the dragon
will be a great show
now it may never reach the height that
game of thrones did but let's keep it
real
very few shows ever will if you're still
on the fence then all i can really do is
back up what david said
give it a chance and you might be
surprised by how much you actually like
it
now if you're still not interested well
then thanks for watching anyway
leave me your thoughts down below how
good do you think house of the dragon
will be
as always i have to thank everyone for
stopping by and checking out my video
i hope all of you have a great day i
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you